this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
best-selling author ramsey personality
and podcast host dr john deloney is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about your relationships your mental
wellness your job your career your money
your life it all shows up right here and
we'll talk about you baby right in front
of you it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five some
say the advice is worth exactly what you
pay for it triple eight
eight two five five
two two five thank you for jumping in
john delony has a book coming out
tuesday the class here is ticking it's
here it's here it's it's kind of like
having a baby it likes never gets here
and then all of a sudden it's here i
used that analogy with my wife the other
day and it wasn't just no you should
never ever use that analogy ever yeah
yeah well i'm a grandpa so i can get
away with it
just me and you and a couple of our
buddies nobody tell anybody we said that
okay that's right but yeah i'm excited
man yeah next week is book launch week
uh it will land on tuesday if you
haven't gotten your copy of or ordered
your copy pre-owned pre-ordered your
copy of own your past change your future
you should
uh it is a book that will bring healing
it's a book that will bring laughter it
is a book that will help you get your
head around things you haven't even
thought about maybe before and it's
certainly not for people who are
mentally ill
um
although it'd probably help but it's
more for like the rest of us that um we
all need a a a framework to process the
crap that happens to us and the good
things that happens to us and this gives
is a great great framework that's really
what it comes down to on your past
change your future uh he'll be in
phoenix on thursday april 21st signing
books that would be a week from
yep today week from today at 6 00 pm the
desert ridge marketplace oh that's a
good store i've done signings there and
dallas and barnes noble prestonwood town
center again a good store and that would
be the following wednesday uh he'll be
doing lots of media and appearances all
across the nation that's the two book
signings we're launching right now
letting you know about them so it is
book launch week next week and if you
want the best deal on the book you get
it before
tuesday because you get one
uh month of weekly therapy sessions with
our friends at betterhelp and you get
the audiobook and the ebook all for the
20 to buy in the book which is an
unbelievable deal so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com i'm just going to
start this hour with that because it's
really important we're all it's all top
of mind for us around ramsey right now
we're real proud of john real proud of
this book and
real proud of all of you that have
bought it and are going to benefit from
it like i have when i read it all right
casey is with us in birmingham casey
what's your question
hey i just have a
whole life policy that i've had for
about six years and i know i'm not
supposed to i know
so i'm trying to figure out
do i keep that now that i've you know
been in it for six years or do i go
ahead and get rid of that and you know
and lose whatever money i've kind of put
in if you have a hole in your pocket you
don't keep it
you sew it up okay because the money
keeps going through the pocket hole and
keeps getting lost even though you love
that pair of jeans you still sew up the
hole in your pocket no we're going to
get term life insurance in place
10 to 12 times
your
income to cover your needs or your
family's needs if they miss out on your
income because you're not here
then once you have that in place then
you drop whole life whole life life
insurance is the payday lender of the
middle class
it is 20 times more expensive than term
in order to build up a cash value that
you never get
because when you die they keep the cash
and they only pay the face amount
and so it's a horrible place to park
money it's a bad bad product no one
recommends it in the financial world
anywhere except people that sell it
right there's your hand what about
okay
what about is there any um
uh thought to the process of using that
to help with paying for kids college or
anything like that
okay well
if you if you want to save money at one
percent
to save for your kids college which is
going up at 7.2 percent a year average
um you're not going to catch up
okay
what do i do with that cash value so
i'll get a cash value out of that what
do i do with that money so that i don't
have taxes on that you shouldn't have
any taxes on it be very unusual if you
do your basis in a whole life policy for
tax calculation is the total of all the
premiums you paid in you probably won't
even get that back
and if you get any more than that back
um it's very unusual for you to but if
you're getting more than in six years i
almost guarantee you you won't get that
back but
you might if you get a little bit more
back it's going to be taxed at
ordinary income it's not a it's not an
investment uh it's a it's a
bad product so you're going to be taxed
ordinary income on the gain if there
isn't any but very doubtful you'll have
that i'd say 98 of the time you don't so
anyway the uh what do you do with it you
anytime you have found money you put it
on the baby steps
when the government looks at a
at a sale of something and they say
you know what guys we're not even going
to take that money that's how you know
it's a bad problem
when the irs is like you know what y'all
made a pretty poor decision yeah we're
not gonna let you keep this money we're
gonna
we're gonna even we feel bad for you
because you have a whole life positive
summers with us summers in houston texas
hi summer
hi it's an honor to speak with y'all you
too what's up um
so my question is i'm currently 21 but
i'm already on baby step four about to
graduate and i guess my question is how
should my next financial steps change
since i'm not planning on having kids
yet or buying a house
wow what are you graduating in
um i'll be an accountant a cpa good for
you wow
and you're graduating with no debt
correct we paid cash both my parents and
i okay so you've been working and
getting scholarships and they had some
money to chip in
yes wow why'd it go man that's amazing
you're stunned so when you say you're
worried about making mistakes what are
you worried about falling into
um i feel like i'm already ahead of
where i need to be in life financially
like i have you know extra money that i
don't know what to do with and i feel
like it should be invested but i should
give some of it and i've been doing both
but i still feel like there's more i
could be doing or extra money that i'm
just kind of sitting on yeah
well i would be putting 15 away once you
graduate into retirement as a baby step
four like you said you were
and above that i i might start doing
some long-term investing maybe like an s
p fund
s p 500 fund to park some money for a
house later
you're not in a hurry to buy a house
today
you're not you know worried about kids
today so we're just living and we got a
big pile of money so let's just pile it
over there in that s p 500 and you can
do anything you want to do with it later
um you know it but it'd make a wonderful
put you in a wonderful position maybe
even to pay cash for a house because
you're you're you know you're way ahead
of normal but you're right really where
you should be
if everybody did what you did we'd have
a completely different economy
um because we wouldn't have 1.7 trillion
dollars in student loan debt and that
would that would be that's draining and
sucking the blood out of the economy
uh so you're incredible you've done a
great great job congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey guys we're back on the
road if you want to be in an energy
packed jam-packed arena filled with real
humans to experience what it means to
live life to the fullest we want to have
you check this out
picture all your favorite speakers on
one stage the smart conference is back
we've been three years oh thank you
we're back on the road i'm so happy uh
dallas october 22nd all day long if you
come to the smart conference at the end
of the day i promise you'll be smarter
we're gonna be talking about mental
health we'll talk about your career
we'll talk about your money we'll talk
about millionaires we'll talk about
leadership we'll talk about
everything
so dr john deloney
rachel cruz
ken coleman
all of the ramsey's team and craig and
amy groschell will be speaking on
marriage tickets are only 39 for the
entire day
and this is going to be a blast it is
not yet sold out but it will early as
you know all concerts and sporting
events and everything post pandemic are
selling out very very quickly people
like to be around people it turns out
who knew
so uh check it out go to
ramseysolutions.com
events
october 22nd is a smart conference our
question of the day is from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
and you'll save even more always use the
promo code ramsey it's magic it'll give
you money off today's question comes
from eric in iowa eric writes my
girlfriend and i are 26 and have been
dating for about a year and we both have
similar amounts of student loan debt i
really want to pay off my student loans
within the next couple years because all
of the stress that it causes me my
girlfriend wants to live it up while
we're young and ignore her student loans
for as long as possible i feel guilty
when we spend money on entertainment and
vacations because it's postponing our
journey to becoming debt debt-free
whenever i bring up my concerns about
our spending habits she becomes
dismissive
i'm worried that she views paying off
student loans as an insurmountable
challenge how can i convince her to take
action with me if i can't is this a lost
cause
dave this doesn't sound like it's about
debt it sounds like um about somebody
who loves somebody
and
he keeps trying to say hey this is an
important value for me in the
continuation of our relationship and the
person he loves is saying it's not for
me
and we're going to move on
and that's hard
that's real hard
yeah
it is it's going to be a heartbreak here
yep but either sooner or later yeah
um or
she's going to suddenly grow up one of
the two because she's being a child
um so eric here's the problem the number
one cause of divorce in north america
today the number one thing people fight
about
is money
and money problems and so when you are
not in agreement not in alignment
on the number one problem in marriage
that's like a flare going off warning
warning warning warning warning you're
about to screw up that's what that's
saying right i mean if like the number
one way that your car blows up is when
this one light comes on and it comes on
and it comes off you pull over quick
you're about to blow your freaking car
up i mean
you're not the exception to this okay so
that's what's going on uh that's where
you are and so
regardless of her
motivation her reason her lack of hope
her
or she's just a princess or whatever it
is she's not in alignment with you
and you guys are you're using a lot of
wee language with a girlfriend yeah
okay there's not a we
when it's a girlfriend there's a we date
but we don't have a budget because
there's not a we you're not married
uh when you're married it's a we yeah uh
but until you're married it's not a we
and even when it's a fiance it's not a
we it's a future we but it's not a we
and right now this is just a girlfriend
you said that three times by the way
yeah and i had a buddy who talked to me
he gave me this phrase when it came to
um eating right and um
exercising
and he said man being a hundred pounds
overweight is really hard it's
exhausting your knees hurt your back
it's hard and exercising and losing 100
pounds is really hard so the goal here
isn't avoidance of hard the goal is what
heart are you going to choose
and by not choosing a heart you
automatically choose
something hard that's right so it's not
avoiding the the discomfort so i'll use
that same phrase with with eric
being with somebody that you love who
constantly dismisses a value you have
you constantly feel guilt even when
you're having fun and doing joyful
things together is going to be really
hard it's a hard way to live
and having a conversation with somebody
you love saying i'm scared about debt
i don't want to enter into a marriage
with you and still have this stuff can
we start now is going to be a hard
conversation pick your heart either way
moving forward you're going to have a
hard conversation it's better to have it
on the front end and be honest and be
direct and then move on well i'm afraid
we'll break up well you're going to
break up you're going to break up it's
just a matter of whether it's after
you're married yeah and 200 000 in debt
or whether before you're married and you
don't have her debt yeah
i tell addicts you're going to get a
group you get to choose one or the court
will order you into one you get to pick
you're gonna break up yes does a lawyer
gonna take your money or not right have
the conversation
how much pain and children are gonna be
involved that's the only question so um
yeah this is not the thing so but she
could say okay you know it's a bigger
deal to you and maybe i need to need to
look at this and let's turn around on
eric don't come to her and say hey we
got to get this debt paid off we got
come to her and say there's not a we by
the way i'm scared i'm paying off my
debt and for us to go forward we've got
to be in alignment you can't you can't
like you know
uh i'm not gonna go on vacations that is
not a reason to break up no
not being in alignment on money and how
it's gonna be handled and children and
how they're gonna be handled and if
we're going to have them and in-laws
that are crazy and how we're going to
deal with them and religion these are
the four things the four the four
horsemen that will destroy your marriage
um in-laws
extended family how we're gonna deal
with the crazy extended family because
there's one there's one in every pile
i'm just telling you
and um
the the uh the how are we gonna have
kids and are the inmates gonna run the
asylum or are the kids gonna behave um
all this kind of stuff uh
money how are we gonna handle that are
we going to save are we going to live
within our means are we going to stay
out of debt um are we just going to go
yolo thank god it's friday i'm a child
and which is what she's doing
and um
and you know
we're going to have you know i i believe
in god and i think you're an idiot for
believing in god these are our two
religions this is not gonna work either
so uh it's very very difficult those are
the fourth
most likely things
uh uh value system things heavy
discussions that enter into
the uh uh put poison in the dna of a
marriage yeah and i think beneath that
is
how are we gonna
if you tell me one of your values and i
don't believe it's a value of mine how
am i going to respond am i going to
ignore am i going to blow you off am i
going to say i'll hold your hand and go
deeper down that let's go talk to
somebody let's get some more information
let's go meet with experts
how are we going to approach those
crossroads when we have them um is also
i think it's important man and this just
complete dismissal yeah it's danger will
robinson get out we're going to have
toxic conflict we're going to have
healthy conflict or we're going to have
no conflict which is also toxic conflict
that's right yeah no no yes except that
one's just more insidious because it
poisons everyone around you when a
spouse and a husband are yelling at each
other
everybody knows stay away when they're
just burning the that no conflict and
feel it in the air
everyone's shoulders are tight
just walk in the room and everybody's on
eggshells so all of that to say eric um
yeah if you were my son
uh i would say hey
time to have a what they call it dtr ctr
i learned about that mine the
relationship back when my kids were
teenagers 25 years ago 20 years ago
um yeah it's time to define the
relationship and are we going are we
just dating in which case you get to do
whatever stupid butt stuff you want to
do with your personal life we're just
dating um but if we're moving towards
something more serious than dating which
is the way this is worded um a
requirement of that is a you're not
going to be dismissive of things that
are important to me this matters to me
i'm scared about this and b i'm not
going to be dismissive of you on things
that are important to you
um
and see we've got to be in alignment on
the big things
the little things we can work around but
the big things can't work around those
can't
work around those
luckily they got me and you and we're
perfect husbands and um
and our advice is always right a hundred
percent
eric this is and it was free these are
two guys
tripped and fallen a few times yeah
yeah we've got stars and bruises
i've answered this question about
somebody's been married 10 years
and i've answered this question from
before they ever get married it's a lot
easier before you get married
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author author of the brand
new book that comes out tuesday
own your past
change your future a not so complicated
approach
to relationships mental health
and wellness
you can pre-order your copy along with a
whole bunch of goodies if you pre-order
it
before tuesday at ramseysolutions.com
tyler and jenny are with us on the debt
free stage right here in the studio
what's up guys how are you we are good
excellent cool so where do you guys live
green castle pennsylvania okay what's
that near
it's about 12 hours in a van with three
kids from here
it's near nothing okay cool welcome good
to have you guys how much have you paid
off about 102 000
wow and how long did that take 26 months
26 months and your range of income
during that time 120 to 140 120 to 140.
you guys got after it now if you put
that many kids in a van don't you double
the number of hours effectively it's
like dog years
sounds about right yeah okay except dog
years are seven times right but yeah but
it's not quite seven with get me kids in
favor it's at least double the five
hours is at least like 10. are we there
yet and i've got a p right you got it oh
my gosh so what kind of debt was the 102
000 it was a mortgage oh yes look at
that weird people yes i love it what's
this house worth i'd say about 270.
how old are you two
i'm 38. i'm gonna be 40 this month all
right
and you're the kings of green castle
that's right no question and man you're
so weird with the paid for house
rocking it i love it very very cool so
what happened to you guys 26 months ago
tell us this story yeah well probably a
couple of years before that is really
where it started for us we just had this
this time where month after month after
month
we were spending more than we were
making and it was so frustrating because
we had worked really really hard early
in our marriage to pay off student loans
and you know we didn't have most debt
and to not being able to live off what
we were making was so frustrating and i
remember having conversations together
where i i felt like this was my fault
i'm the financial guy right you know
this is my responsibility what do you do
for a living i work in i.t oh okay all
right what about you
um i was a stay-at-home mom for several
years and when we decided that this was
going to be it i went back to work i
groomed dogs and i taught art lessons at
a local ceramics studio wow good for you
yeah
but i mean like i said it just reached
this breaking point and jenny was really
encouraging she said you know this is
not your fault we're in it together and
she said i think we have a book
downstairs maybe we could read it and i
knew exactly which book she was talking
about uh the problem was i had taken it
and given it away 10 years ago because i
definitely did not need to read anything
that you guys you know had to say sure
um so you know hindsight
so but but we remembered the name and we
started looking at now this is how i
sell two books to everyone exactly
yup actually he went downstairs and
grabbed harry potter one and he's like
are we gonna read this and she was like
yeah but but we found your content and
we started really absorbing it and just
crushing it and that's when we came up
with really our first budget in our
entire marriage um and we learned how to
track it i mean that was that was key
for us i mean and again hindsight that's
so obvious you know
measure what you want to get results in
so we came up with a budget and and you
know things were going really really
well for us and then we went through
financial peace university wow so that
was kind of like next level and then we
started going through every line item on
that budget you know we were switching
utility companies if they didn't meet
what we wanted we were making all kinds
of insurance changes
and it was really really cool and we
felt in control of our money for
probably the first time in our marriage
how long you been married 17 years this
year yep wow yep
but really the coolest part for us in
this whole journey i mean the mortgage
was really exciting but once we got to
this point in our journey
god put a ministry opportunity in front
of us and he told us that two kids
needed to come live with us for a while
and before this process absolutely we
would have said no to that because we
couldn't afford it um but we said yes
and the girls were with us for almost a
year
um and when they moved back in with
their mom is when we really sat down and
said you know what god uh god put this
opportunity in front of us when we got
our financial house in order
what happens you know what's he gonna
ask us to do if we pay this house off
what what good can we do when that
happens so we sat down and made a plan
for it i think plan number one was like
hey six years let's just put a little
bit in a month and a six year plan and
i'm not that patient
so we worked it we worked it for a year
and then jenny said yes she's not very
patient and i love her very much
but she said yeah what does it take to
get through this in a year and so we did
the math and that's when she started
working two or three jobs at the same
time and we just really got after it
and it was a team effort i mean our kids
were a big part of it usually when one
of us was weak and said hey i want to go
get chipotle for dinner one of the kids
would say dad is this in the budget
shoot no it's not um so we may not have
been gazelle intense for that but we
were like wounded gazelle
and so it was awesome so we got it
knocked out at the end of last year and
it's it's been fantastic wow and the
kids like ours was just to pay off the
debt but our kids we told them that when
it was paid off we would give them each
20 to go to the grocery store and buy
whatever they wanted because we had been
on this budget for so long and so that
was their like no we can't do that
because we're waiting for this grocery
store i could not go to chipotle until i
get my 20 bucks all right and nowadays
20 bucks will buy you three pieces of
cheese yeah
but it was a fun celebration when we got
to that point it was awesome that's very
cool guys very cool what's the best um
marriage disagreement y'all had over the
last couple years
it's probably been about this budget
and how long it was taking ah
yeah
but it's cool to be on the other side of
it i mean we still use the budget we
still track it just now we're not
writing a check out to a mortgage
company which is super exciting for me i
feel like we're writing that check out
to us you are writing it out to you you
get to keep your money that's right you
need ideas that's right i love it yeah
you don't have to wash dogs anymore
that's so fantastic you know i love it i
still do oh man good for you jenny's a
hard worker good for you
all right what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you paid
off your house before you were 40.
yeah i mean i think one of the big
pieces for us is recognizing that the
money is not ours this is god's money
that he's entrusted with us and i think
when you have that mentality you know
you want to do good with it you know you
want to do the best you can with it um
and so that was a really big help i know
for me
and i think the other part for us was
when you have a common goal with your
spouse uh it's pretty incredible um when
we started this i did not expect that
jenny and i would be growing so much
closer together but when you come
together in a goal
it's just amazing um how you grow in
your relationship yeah
that's powerful right and the grass does
feel different
yeah nice to take your shoes off and
walk through the backyard we did when
there is no mortgage it was winter
it's amazing to see uh your three kids
are still breathing after
having been told no for a few years
right
they've made it somehow they're still
clothed they've got shoes their hair is
great
well done everybody you've broken some
myths yeah yeah very good good job yeah
there's something about like you said
when you start realizing you're managing
money for someone else when a person of
honor
realizes uh i have to take care of this
for someone else when i'm managing god's
money for him instead of my money for me
uh it changes because you you will do
things for other people you wouldn't do
for yourself yeah you know you'll
sacrifice at a different level which is
it's kind of an
interesting dynamic to me but uh we had
the same exact experience in the ramsey
house so congratulations you guys are
very proud of you you're rock stars man
so uh you've been investing in your
401ks and in your iras and your
retirement how much is in there i'd say
about three hundred and thirty thousand
dollars so far okay so you're you're
gonna be uh
45 you're going to be uh baby steps
millionaires next couple years we're
watching closely yeah you're right on
track way to go guys i'm so proud of you
45 year old millionaires looking at us
they're not there yet but they'll be
there soon and uh with a paid for house
we've got a copy of the uh baby steps
millionaires book for you because you're
on that track for sure that's the next
chapter in your story and a copy of
total money makeover since you gave
yours away and you can now give it away
again this time stir up a ruckus what
are the kids names and ages
uh so we have nate is our oldest he's
12. josh is 10 and cora is six all right
everybody's looking good all right
there's the 20 gang right there that's
what that's what we're going to call
them i like it tyler and jenny from
pennsylvania along with nate joss and
cora 102 000 paid off in 26 months house
and everything
we're looking at weird people count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Applause]
so great
awesome i love it
about as good as it gets right there
gentlemen
ladies that's how it works
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five murray is in
gettysburg pennsylvania hi murray
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi dr john i appreciate you guys
helping me with my question today sure
what's up
so i have uh
my best friend growing up he grew up
here with me in pennsylvania he moved to
california he's been within there for a
few years um he's getting very soon
which is very exciting um naturally i'm
the i'm the best fan from pulling
together the bachelor pardon for him out
there
um it's going to be kind of close to la
so it's pretty expensive i'm of course
as the best man i'm covering
all the parts for him uh you know for
the groom but uh i have i have rented an
airbnb there um which is pretty
expensive uh a month ago i've got i got
everybody saying that you know like the
one i chose was a good option um it was
a lot versus the last weekend in may
like right before memorial day yeah we
just i just managed to book it i did
front the money for it and uh today i
thought like you know i haven't had
anyone pay yet for it and uh today i had
someone reach out to one of his friends
from california saying like well i kind
of live close anyway i'll come hang out
with you guys uh but i won't stay the
night so therefore i won't have to like
you know pay my part for the airbnb and
now his other friend who's out there
like i don't know if there's
collaborating but like he's kind of
given the same kind of messages but
hasn't what he said he hasn't like
really decided yet um
so i i'm just kind of wondering like do
i just kind of eat the cost for their
portions how much is the money
it's it's it worked out to be about 200
dollars a person including the groom so
i'm covering his total out of pocket for
the total to rent the airbnb was how
much
um it was like around 800 bucks yeah
what do you make a year
so i i do have plenty of money to cover
it's not a money not really as much of a
money issue
um like we together my wife and i make a
little over 150 so that's
i think i just need to get over and just
realize they're his friends and or
cancel it cancel it man
or tell them they can't come if they
don't pay i mean you're running the show
here i i'm just going to lean into dave
push back i i'm just going to lean into
what
i'm not gonna carry other people's
stress and if i'm gonna go to the
wedding anyway and i'm gonna plan for a
good evening
it stinks man but it
is what it is
you know i i i might
the most i would ever do is maybe one
message back and i would just say
you know i booked this based on each of
everyone paying their part it's
disappointing that you won't but
whatever yeah
and just i would shame them a little
yeah here's my venmo okay like here's my
venmo and then dude i'm not going to
give it another second thought yes it
stinks it's the worst blah blah blah
yeah you've already stressed more than
800 bucks over it yeah and you and you
guys are thinking the same thing even
like because i'll be drinking and stuff
at night and like you know not not crazy
or anything i'm like 30 but you know how
that is but i like it i know some 30
year olds that can still get after it
now but yeah i might say hey uh i'm
going to cover this or yeah i mean
here's the thing make peace with what
you want to do you're trying to make
everybody happy here and at the same
time you have this need that you want
met which is everybody contributing
their fair part and at some point you
have to run up against that fantasy and
say that's not happening
and so what's the picture of the party
that i was asked by the groom to throw
and i'm gonna lean into that and
i get to decide who's there and who's
not and i mean you get to make all these
calls make the decisions just move on
with your life you're not going to make
everybody happy and have everybody give
like meet all your needs too
yeah i think i think between her and i
we were like disappointed about
everything but we were kind of i think
we were kind of leaning towards just
like whatever happens happens like i'm i
won't i don't want to ruin the groom's
time by like telling people they can't
come or they can't spend their nights
just have two different coolers for paid
and didn't pay
one of them's gonna be full of capri
suns and one of them's gonna be full of
really nice drinks
okay that's what i would do and there's
gonna be like four hot dogs and then
there's gonna be catered food for those
who paid mignon that's right in hot dogs
right i mean you can have some fun with
it man just like dave dave said
all this is a soul tax
that 800 you've you've put in more than
800 worth of worry when it comes to the
balance on your net worth let it ride
man yeah i i i probably if it was my
buddies or of these these aren't
actually your buddies they're friends of
the groom that are being twerps they're
not your friends uh i'd probably just
send them a note and say hey i booked
this on the idea that everybody was
going to pay their fair share if you
don't want to i'm more concerned about
the groom's happiness than i am mine or
yours if you don't want to pay your part
that's okay but i did book it based on
your word that you were coming yeah and
just leave it like at that and you know
just call their honor out and shame them
a little i would and feel free to bring
your own drinks and then drop it yeah
and then drop it and uh oh by the way
it's gonna be byob for you
exactly
no i'm kidding i'm done just but you
gotta
the thing is
you're a person of uh that that
uh
values honor
and uh it's a big d these kinds of
details are a big deal to you
uh in your personality style and the way
you're wired and your upbringing um
that's not true for everyone
and when you run into people that it's
not you you've got to turn you got to
learn to let them loose because they're
not you're not going to change them
and and you know you're either going to
stir this up and make it a big deal or
you're just going to let it go and it's
not a big deal or the third option is
you can just choose to see and you're
going to you're choosing misery when you
do that yeah that's just a
silly way to choose yeah
frank's in akron ohio hey frank welcome
to the ramsay show hey dave thanks for
taking my call sure how can we help
so i'm a big fan i read the book my
total money makeover i'm going to read
baby steps eventually but i have a
question today because
i have student loans and i pulled out a
mortgage in 2020
and the student loans keep on getting
deferred and they were supposed to be
due may 1st and then they got deferred
till september 30th and i really don't
know what congress wants to do with
these loans and i don't really bank on
the federal government but i'm almost
like thinking that this might be one of
those things like forgive one day just
to get more votes so i don't know if i
should be paying those right now because
there's zero interest or
maybe
investing instead
that was kind of my yeah
well um
here's the thing i i've been doing this
a long time
and the number of times i have met
someone who was
uh had their life financially changed
positively
by the people in washington dc
is zero
okay so if you're waiting on your life
to be good because of something that
they do with the island of misfit toys
up there your life's always going to
suck
because you're always waiting you're
always waiting on them to grow a brain
and they don't have them they don't have
a single brain between all of them put
together up there
so um it's not gonna happen
uh listen the democrats ran on the idea
that they were gonna forgive student
loans they're in control the house the
senate and the white house and they've
not presented a single bill for student
loan forgiveness
don't you call bs at this point
i am
and so no they're not going to pay them
off they're not going to forgive them
not anytime soon anyway and you need to
get this stuff out of your life
as soon as you possibly can the tragedy
is is that all these interest payments
have been delayed and then delayed and
then delayed and yet six out of ten
student loans have not made any payments
during this time instead of taking
advantage of the lack of
thrust and crushed it they're sitting
back and waiting on aoc to fix their
life and honey she ain't gonna do it
so no you need to get this paid off as
fast as you can
um anything to add to that i've got i've
got an unpopular take on this um
and it's this
i signed up my wife and i had to pay off
six figures of student loan debt we
signed up for a million
a million different loans
but at the end of the day
i looked at somebody and looked him in
the eye and shook their hand and said if
you will help me get through school i'll
pay you back and so i always felt a
moral obligation now i notice people who
are tricked i know there's people who
are
asked to sign stuff they don't fully
understand absolutely i'm all about
taking care of them but for most of us
we signed our name on the piece of paper
we just didn't do the math we didn't
fully get a have a picture of what we
were going to be asked to do over the
next 20 or 30 years and so i say don't
wait on the government do the right
thing you sign your name pay the stupid
things off and let's get on about your
life yeah while you use all these
interest rate breaks these interests
burn through the prison way to burn it
up and get rid of it
instead of standing back and waiting on
someone in the white house to fix your
life
never do that on any subject
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author and host of the dr
john deloney show is my co-host
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage dan and marie are with
us hey guys how are you great how are
you doing awesome honored to have you
guys where do you live phoenix arizona
cool cool welcome to nashville how much
data you paid off one million
275 and 384 dollars
okay
that's a heck of a phone bill you two 1
275 000 yes
all right and uh but i i'm trying to get
my speech back here and uh
how long did this take took four years
and nine months four years and nine
months and your range of income during
this time started at 62 000 and ended at
300 000. cool what do y'all do for a
living
so we actually have a
store called the yard in phoenix arizona
or stone suppliers or kitchen and
countertops as well as bathrooms so yeah
okay very cool good good and um so
there's got to be a story here obviously
indeed oh my goodness gracious uh what
happened and what in the world kind of
debt was this well
we're serial entrepreneurs dan's owned
many businesses since he was 14 and
we've owned the yard for 12 years but in
the middle of that we decided to go open
another business
that business took us on a roller
coaster ride it failed miserably and in
2016 we sold that business or sorry we
closed that business
and our other business was hanging on by
a thread never was profitable to that
point and we had
50 000 personal credit cards 55 000 in
vehicles 80 000 personal loans nine
hundred and thirty thousand business
debt and 155 000 it was our home
wow
so how do you turn this around in four
years these kinds of numbers
well
um good question
before you answer that it's important if
you're just listening to this dan as she
told that story
you your eyes went to the floor
your shoulders struck i mean you
you still feel that huh absolutely those
were dark dark moments because you knew
how much money that was
absolutely
so what inspired the change and what did
you do so when we closed the business
the other business it was really hard we
were emotionally physically exhausted
our children were young
and i was at home doing laundry our
other business was barely hanging on and
we were living off of personal loans and
credit cards and i was listening to a
mom podcast and rachel cruz was on that
christian mom podcast featuring her book
love your not life not theirs and i was
like oh yeah dave ramsey mom and dad
taught me about that
and i went online and we found that you
were having a one day entre leadership
event in pasadena california which
ironically was five years ago this past
monday
and we attended that event and it was
like drinking from a fire hose we
realized that we were terrible business
owners we were not strong leaders we
didn't know our numbers we had donkeys
working for us and we felt like you gave
us all these tools in one day and we
were like oh my goodness we have to go
home and change everything
and we took six hours to drive home and
um we just talked non-stop like oh my
goodness we have to like restart
everything um you know we had been
business owners for a long time but um
it was like we had all these tools now
so that's where we started that that
event gave us the hope
to say okay we can do this this isn't
going to be a lifelong curse for us
that's amazing that's i'm
wow
so you just put on the hustle on the
grind
yeah we and plowed through it
we went home and we got rid of everybody
or they self-selected
so we started over we started to learn
what the problems were
and it took several months and then it
was like god just turned on the faucet
and he just blessed our business
immensely and
we started living how his word told us
all along that we didn't pay attention
to and um everything changed absolutely
everything changed powerful
just in time for the whole world to get
stuck at home and decide they want to
start a remodel project you got it
what a couple of years right
hey you couldn't have done that no if
you hadn't gone through the darkness of
the previous few years indeed indeed
yeah
it's been a long journey that's for sure
yeah
and yet 2020 was probably a banner year
income wise it was yeah it's like you're
in the plexiglass business or something
oh my god that's right
yeah everybody loves their countertops
man yeah i mean anything home
improvement went bonkers yep that year
so yeah you couldn't find anything
because it was just everybody sitting at
home and go i never noticed that before
but i got to fix that you know and it
just the home improvement stuff went
nuts
yeah so you're staring at 1.2 million
dollars
how do you head into that darkness
well like marie said i mean
for me it was
at that
one day event
it was just a mountain that was in front
of us and we had a small shovel
and it was like day by day that was like
here we go another shovel
another shovel
and um
i'll never forget
you know dave you kind of closed off
with that winston churchill speech
never give up
and there's so many times i wanted to
give up
there were so many times where i had
doubt
there were many times they were fearful
but through many
friends and our family supported us
through this
um
i'm just humbled by god's goodness
and his blessing amen
amen that's powerful
huh that is so powerful um
usually
when folks go through climb a mountain
this large
there's
periodic uh
maybe two times maybe once during that
time where it clicked and you went
wait a minute
this is going to freaking work
do you remember when that was
well there's many times when i remember
it not working
the first year we paid off i think 32
000 which was really hard to do and i'm
like oh my goodness if we continue at
this rate it's going to take us 42 years
it feels like it's going to be forever
yeah and
then i think that we came to summit when
it was held here at headquarters and we
went home we're like oh man how much
more do we have and we did the numbers
and we're like oh man that was 20. still
a lot yeah yeah just the other day yeah
okay and um i don't know then then it
just the snowball just
just
gained momentum and
and we were managing our business much
better which then gave us more
you know liquid to be able to pay off
the debt and um
i remember paying off our house and
being like
this doesn't feel real this doesn't feel
real you know
[Music]
but that big honking 900 000 business
loan man that was the beasty
indeed and now you don't owe anybody
anything no how does it feel when that
check deposits and it's all yours it's
incredible
incredible now if you if you're
listening
dan's everything changed now look at it
your hands are behind your back now in a
bring it on posture you're smiling look
at that man it's amazing
gosh and even just the
opportunity to bless our team you know
we have a team of you know 24 people
that work for us and so being able to
pay them what they're worth
bless them in amazing ways you know we
weren't able to do that before
and you got ones now that you want to
bless indeed yeah that's a big that's a
big deal yeah
yeah it's powerful i'm so proud of you
guys you're an amazing story wow
very very very well done well we've got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
story if you're not already past it
and uh obviously a copy of the total
money makeover too
you brought the kettles with you what
are their names and ages
um we've got jacob
he's 16 julia she's 14 ava she's 12 and
autumn she's eight all right very good
well done you guys beautiful family
well done well done man that's amazing
well that's the most debt uh debt-free
stream that we've had this year
so we're at 19 million dollars in debt
free screams for the calendar year so
far and you just added another million
275 000 to it rowdy i love it i love it
i love it all right dan and marie jacob
julia ava and autumn count it down
1.275 paid off in four years and nine
months let's hear the
debt-free scream
three
two one
[Music]
yeah oh my goodness
this is the ramsay ship
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage it's back-to-back debt
free screams landon and samantha are
with us where do you guys live
clarksville tennessee clarksville just
up the road very scary what do you all
do for a living
i'm a dental hygienist
and i own my own business cool doing
what uh lawn care good control excellent
excellent what kind of day how much debt
did you pay off 400 and 1 000. 401 how
long did this take three years
and one thousand yes in three years and
your range of income during that time
fifty four thousand to a hundred and
eighty four thousand well there's a nice
jump yes sir
you've been pulling a lot of weeds
hopefully not
[Laughter]
somebody asked she's been pulling a lot
of teeth man
well
something's going on here all right well
done guys what kind of debt was the 400
and 1 000
35 student loans and the rest is the
house you paid off your house
yes sir couple weird people
i love it
what's this house worth
about 500 000 wow good for you well done
guys how old are you guys
i'm 31
i'm 29 and you're paid for house
did you ever think
he probably did
i did not
all right tell us the story how did this
happen in the last three years
well we got married and uh i've never
been in debt besides mortgages and um
i had a rental house too
and it was two hours away and i started
getting nervous as far as it taken care
of and once we got married i said let's
pay off the student loan and then
i didn't think we were going to be able
to get the house paid off that quick but
god blessed us with my business so
i was not on
board why not what oh my parents and i
mean we just lived life and were able to
go and do and
they didn't care
whether we had paid off stuff or not
so all right so how did you get on board
what happened
i got stuck on i-65 for eight hours and
listened to your podcast
snow storm or he just pulled over the
side of the road
at the beach
oh driving to the beach okay we weren't
stuck or drunk you were stuck in the car
in the car
i got it okay i'm catching on now oh my
gosh and at the end of that at the end
of that beach trip you're like okay
we'll do it well there was no
we'll do it okay
so did you sell the rental yes sir what
did it bring
185 000. okay so that was almost half of
this well i owed a hundred thousand oh i
apologize i profited around okay 70 000.
so it was a fourth of this then yes sir
okay was the 400 all your mortgage or
does that include that mortgage you paid
off the sale the rental they included
all of it oh okay all right so it was
185 85 moved to your mortgage and 100
got rid of so it's 185 of the 400
was it when that went with that one move
yeah very good good awesome good but
still 200 grand now 250 000 bucks
roughly uh in three years that's pretty
stinking amazing well done well done
i love it i love it so what was your
best disagreement you all had
got to eat i bet you had some juices
i like to go out to eat
[Laughter]
yeah that's probably the worst argument
i was like no
rice and beans
ramen that's what i chose i never ate
lunch in high school just to save my
money so
you've been a tight wad your whole life
yeah okay he still has clothes for
middle school
so it sounds like cosmically you all
both need each other right yes we're
very opposite but needed
i love it and then we have a baby dude
in there mma
all right yeah
i love it oh very good congratulations
to you guys
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is samantha
oh
don't go well when people ask you to go
out to eat just don't go
make sure you bring your lunch
or your husband will track your location
like what are you doing
sure looks like you're hanging out in
front of a chipotle you're probably
mexican
but um how come yourself speaking
spanish
i mean
i don't know
what do you think what do you think
just getting over yourself really
you don't deserve that new car if you
can't afford it and just don't worry
about what you look like
i could care less if people think i'm
broke i know what my bank looks like and
i don't have to have so much stress and
my family's taken care of
how's it feel to be completely debt free
samantha
was it worth it oh yeah definitely yeah
so you'd do it again i would i would
even with the restaurants but i did it
again yeah all right what do you think
landon what's it like being in a house
that you don't owe anybody anything
it's nice running the business you know
you
sometimes have to do things you wouldn't
do and now i can kind of
not have to have so much stress i
we're taking care of no matter what yeah
beautiful man yes the interesting thing
is is that you don't have to take
clients that give you more trouble than
they're worth absolutely there's a lot
of those and the net and the net net net
is you end up making more exactly uh
it's strange uh with a little bit of
that desperation gone
your business runs a little smoother
it's on a little better rhythm
um from strength rather than from
desperation and it just becomes more
profitable it almost always happens that
way
well done you guys i'm very proud of
y'all y'all are neat you're fun thanks
very fun you did a great job we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
i bet you're already there are you
landon
almost i'll be there before 35. okay all
right he's got it figured out he does
have it figured out
it's going to be a 35 year old baby
steps millionaire not if she can
restaurant her way she may maybe
thirteen we're gonna eat after this
that's right
i've already picked out a nashville
restaurant i'm just saying i love it way
to go you guys also a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away and
bless somebody and stir up a ruckus in
their life and uh very very very cool
very well done all right landon and
samantha clarksville tennessee 401 000
paid off in three years house and
everything
29 and a little bit more i love it i
love it i love it fifty four thousand
hundred and eighty four thousand dollar
income count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three three two
one yes
[Applause]
that'll do i love it that may have been
the greatest debt free stream that was
that fit the couple the best yeah the
fit the couple the best that's exactly
right i like it
well it's uh uh
you know she's fun because she's she's
uh authentic yeah yeah and given the eye
roll yeah yeah oh no stuck on 65 with
dave ramsey in the car i can't get out
and uh and yet here we are four hundred
thousand dollars at 30 years old in zero
debt zero house or anything
that's pretty stinking powerful
it's a lot of fun wow very 400 that's
1.6 million dollars paid off in the last
two jeffrey screams
that's a lot of freedom that's true
almost 1.7 yeah hey can we can can we
poke on something real quick yep they
mentioned in the last debt free screen
and i know it's the same here too
because they don't owe anybody any money
they don't owe anybody money they're
able to
take care of the people that work for
them in a different way
which then ends up blessing their
families
and it makes their kids go to school
with a little bit less stress and helps
that teacher out so if you will in your
home
we get so concerned with how the
national if you will fix your home
the derivative the ripple effect peace
that you pass along is
incalculable it's you can follow the
math on it it really does happen it's
amazing it's it's actually powerful i
mean how do you you know how can i be a
blessing to a teacher yeah
well send a kid that's not stressed out
to school why are they not stressed out
because my household is being run on a
system and we're debt-free and mom and
dad are in agreement and we're not
boundaries the kids sleep we're not
yelling at each other we're not yelling
at the kids you know we're not out of
con you know there's mental health all
over this man mental wellness all over
this
oh and by the way the team you know
becomes the best place to work yeah yeah
because it is the best place to work
hello people want to do business with
you because you tell the truth and you
show up you do good work and so you make
more money because i don't have to put
up with your crap if you're one of those
other people you know i don't i don't
have tolerance for you anymore i
keep that out of my life you bring drama
i don't want drama and crazy i keep
drawing i lock the door the drama and
crazy use i don't want a mute coming in
here
[Music]
what's going on inside your house
changes the whole
deal
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today his brand new book own
your past change your future comes out
on tuesday we are in the middle of book
launch week one week from today it comes
out it'll be mailed to you folks that
have pre-ordered it thank you to all of
you thousands tens of thousands of you
who have bought this book already we
will be shipping them out promptly i
promise we are not having any issues
we've got them here in the house we're
ready to go
everything's happening john's been doing
a ton of media we're getting emails in
while we're on the air today that he and
i will be doing appearances he'll be
doing appearances uh all regarding this
book launch in the next few days weeks
and months he did a big one this morning
in dallas with my friend down there mark
davis and uh that was a live hit wasn't
it yeah yeah so that's already happened
and uh good
and so hey if you want this brand new
book uh it's only twenty dollars if you
pre-order it it comes along with the
ebook and the audio book as read by the
author and that's a pain in the butt
isn't it oh man that's a hard thing it
is
people don't have any idea how hard it
is to read a book for five hours that
you wrote it's super important not to
miss a single
word oh it came out of your head and now
you're reading the word yeah it's it's
it's uh it's how many how many errors
did you find while you were rereading it
oh dave i found three when i was
rereading baby steps millionaire one of
them was bad oh dave we had several that
were uh several a a lot we had a lot i
don't know yeah oh no
yeah yeah we had some good back and
forth i had three that were very
distinct and
made my face turn red yeah and not for
once from embarrassment once from anger
yeah yeah so there you go anyway all
right so
uh as too much authenticity here as read
by the author of the audiobook oh and by
the way uh if you find those mistakes
and you need therapy that's right
i myself
better help is uh going to give you a
month of through free weekly therapy
sessions and uh hey this is a book all
about mental wellness
uh if you go well this is a book for
crazy people no it's not we're all a
little crazy if you're very honest about
it but we've all got stuff that we go
okay there's a thing in my past there
and if i somehow could put that in a
different bucket i probably could move
forward in a different way a different
framework a different way of looking at
it and own your past change your future
is the framework it's going to show you
how to do it it's a not so complicated
way to do relationships mental health
and mental wellness so check it out you
can pre-order it now at
ramseysolutions.com please go ahead and
get it before tuesday so you get the
deals
also be ahead those of you in phoenix be
marking it on your calendar a week from
today april the 21st john will be
signing books at the desert ridge
marketplace on tatum boulevard the
barnes and noble there be sure and i
head up there and get your book signed
by john at 6 00 p.m on that thursday the
following wednesday april the 27th
barnes and noble in dallas at the
prestonwood town center on beltline road
6pm there so he'll be out doing a media
and some speaking events and so forth
and those two cities and lots of other
things through the coming week as we get
this uh
get this push on
uh this book launch and and finish up um
you know the the marketing process here
but we don't market things around here
that we don't know are going to help
this is a transformative book if you
ever wish you had dr john dolone sitting
across the table from you telling you
how it is helping you being
compassionate with you that's what he's
going to do through this book it's going
to be just like he was sitting there
don't miss this thing so get it at
rimmel the coolest thing that's happened
today over the last few weeks is doing
media and having the media personalities
or the podcaster
write me personally and said
i skimmed through this for the interview
i read it after the interview
and it's it's become meaningful to them
and that's what they do for a living and
that's been that's been some neat
feedback i can't wait till it hits it
gets out into the world you know we were
actually talking about that in one of
the planning meetings i was talking to
all the personalities but you in
particular because this book was coming
out i said if we can write something or
do something on the air
that the uh that the host of the thing
is personally touched by or helped by or
transformed by then we know we've got
something yeah um because
by the way those people in front of the
cameras are microphones they're like
people that's they got kids and they're
trying to figure it out they got dreams
and broken childhoods that's right like
anybody else does yeah and that's the
way it is so open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five ben is
in cedar rapids iowa hi ben welcome to
the ramsey show
hi uh thanks so much for all you guys do
and all the all the help you guys
provide thank you
um so i'm just started listening to you
guys recently i was gifted uh one of
your books and now i listen to you guys
while driving for about four hours a day
whoa um
yeah reruns usually but um
i i'm somewhere i think i'm done with
baby step number one heading into baby
step number two which
you know long story short i screwed up
the first half of my life
and
i'm trying to do a big turnaround i just
don't know where to put house repairs
because i have several major house
repairs coming up major
give me an example give me an example of
a major house repair
i have a hole in my roof uh that's
leaking water into the attic small hole
uh we get bats into our house an average
of one to two times per year
and our a track
system is about 30 years old it still
works great
but it's 30 years old and i know i need
to plan for it what's your household
income
uh between me and my wife is 80 000
that's good news okay
and um how much debt do you have not
counting your home
let's see total debt or not increasing
the home
yes sorry looking at the spreadsheet
it's it includes the home um
137 with the home and the home is about
85 000
620 with us 50 grand and you make 80. so
you're going to be debt-free in two
years if you do what we teach
okay
uh beans and rice rice and beans don't
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there living on a budget
you and your spouse are in agreement
we're selling everything but the kids
and the kids are worried
okay
and um the dog and the cat are on
craigslist i mean we're getting that
we're getting this done right so um i'm
kidding keep the dog but um definitely
sell the cat though
i've been working on that good
give the cat away whatever yeah pay
people to take the cat but the uh anyway
so uh
then having said that
uh what you've got to ascertain is what
is an emergency
and what is impending doom impending
doom in your case is the hvac system if
we can keep that puppy pi patched
together with duct tape for two years
and get you out of debt you'll be able
to cash flow a good heat and air system
if you don't then spend the minimal
amount to patch it and k and let it limp
through until you get this two-year 18
months to two years to clear the fifty
thousand dollars
okay and then start talking about saving
up the money to replace it
uh don't go in debt to replace it under
any circumstances
be hot be hot okay buy a fan
uh buy a heater okay whatever you got to
do to limp through i did this okay
when our kids when we went the year we
went through bankruptcy the heating air
went out on our house and i hired a guy
for 300 bucks instead of 4 000 to put a
used compressor in and it made it
exactly 18 months that 300 bucks bought
me 18 more months and then i was able to
be clear and i was able to save up and
put a good air conditioner full full-on
you know compressor and everything on
the back of the house and and do it
right i also oddly enough had a water
leak in the roof the year
that uh that we went bankrupt and
decided we don't borrow money anymore
the guy came out gave us a bid for a new
roof it was eight thousand dollars eight
thousand dollars might as well been
eight million because we were so broke
we couldn't pay attention
and so um i went to the hardware store
and got some of that i got a five gallon
bucket of that tar stuff and went up
there and smeared it on the roof like
white trash
and um it quit leaking quit running it
was running through the light fixture uh
dripping on the on the kitchen table so
it's also a fire hazard because it's
water running through the light fixture
right so but it quit leaking it looked
like crap but it quit leaking and again
i made it another 18 months with that
ugly roof on there and the neighbors
probably would have called hoa if there
was one
and um but we got through it and then we
put a roof on it with cash i don't know
what your version of that with the bats
is but the that's the way you're gonna
do it something like that try to hold on
try to get through with a minimal until
you can get debt free and you pay cash
to do the repairs properly that's how
you work them in
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author host of the dr john
dolone show is my co-host this hour this
is a very special hour on the ramsey
show it is a teacher appreciation hour
as we do talk as we talk about and
celebrate financial literacy month this
month in the schools and uh we
appreciate all teachers
in the process of doing about doing
something about that and doing something
about everything that they do out there
teachers are
absolutely amazing my grandmother ramsey
was a second grade teacher
uh my aunt taught uh
uh taught
until just the other day she retired
after almost 40 years or maybe over 40
years now
taught math in the knoxville public
school system
my other aunt taught in
the atlanta school system
my cousin's wife is a teacher i mean
i've got teachers all over my family i'm
a teacher actually i'm just a little
weirder and wilder than
than some of the others but teachers
teachers change the world man oh yeah
and so we we love teachers and financial
literacy is absolutely important
i john i'll never forget the first time
i had those little blue
self-published financial piece books
they were pretty lame
uh i didn't sell 35 000. those are your
words not mine go ahead but they they
well they no they they are lame i mean
it's it's pretty much certifiable there
there are facts and that's a fact
but i did sell 35 000 of them you were
just saying the words in them weren't
lame but the production of the book
itself all that but i'm i was one of the
first times i went to speak and i had
the books for sale i would go up front
speak with like an overhead projector
and all this stuff and then the the book
table was at the back with the workbooks
and the books were for sale for 12 and
i'd run back there and sell books and i
remember a lady came back there at one
of the first breaks where i was talking
about getting out of debt and living on
a lesson you make and getting on a
budget
and she picked up that little blue book
and she goes
why isn't this taught in the schools
i mean like that was the first
year
of me doing this 30 years ago
and i have heard that
25 000 times since
because we've all thought it
why isn't financial literacy taught in
schools how is it that you can get out
of school and know what the pythagorean
theorem is but can't do a budget
[Music]
how is that possible so we started doing
something about it several decades ago
we
started a high school curriculum with
our financial materials
it is now called foundations in personal
finance
it has now been taught in almost half of
the high schools in america about 48 of
the high schools in america have now
taught it over 4 million students have
already taken these classes
we're now running into 26 year olds 28
year olds that are getting married
and with no doubt went through college
with no debt and married someone who
agreed to be debt-free and stay
debt-free so that they can become
wealthy because they went through
foundations of personal finance in high
school
not because they went through financial
peace university at 25
but because they went through
foundations and personal finance because
this should be taught in the schools and
now by god it is if your school wants it
you can get it and we put it in there
it's that simple so uh and of course the
the
the hinge pin on which all of this spins
the the key component the keystone that
allows all of this to happen is called a
teacher
teachers make the world go around they
have a bigger impact on kids
than anybody gives them credit for and
and to in today's world with crazy butt
school boards and helicopter parents i
don't know how they do it i don't either
i yeah i've i've been a high school
teacher an elementary school teacher my
wife too it's tough and it has just
accelerated and dave if i was a high
school teacher i would be in jail for
murder
yeah but night of the students of
protecting the crazy adults in their
lives take out one of the one of the
administrators or the parent i just take
them out the few teachers i've talked to
personally
it seems like this becomes a mission for
an individual teacher
to to to they often bring it to the
school and say this is important this is
important teacher financial literacy
pieces financial literacy and they
champion it yeah but yeah being a
teacher these days is tough tough tough
stuff
well it's
critical and
we're
we're we're at a um
we're approaching a crisis point
in two or three
segments of our culture that are
some that are some of the most important
glue that hold our culture together
uh we're losing uh
health care professionals
pastors
police officers police officers and
teachers walking away
because of the coveted ridiculousness
safety education those are pillars
because of the political uh stuff that
has gotten involved in them simply
executing their jobs and doing the
things they're supposed to do and
they're under-appreciated yeah so uh
on the behalf of the teachers
we are
de-let i mean we we are calling
touchdown right here we're saying you're
you rock and we're here to this hour
just to appreciate you and uh to talk to
a few of you so we've reached out to
talk to some of the teachers that have
been teaching the high school curriculum
the foundations in personal finance and
that includes karina ford who is a high
school teacher at rusk high school in
rusk texas is that right karina
yes sir all right very cool thank you
for coming on with us how long have you
been teaching
um this is my 16th year as a teacher and
this is the first time i've ever taught
your course and taught economics wow
okay how's that going
um
it it has been life-changing for some
and then some kids i look and think i
wish you were listening to me
[Laughter]
so basically like me and dave's job
every day right
so how big is this high school how many
kids are there um we have about 600 kids
in our high school as far as texas high
schools go it's considered a foray
okay all right cool all right so there's
a public school then
yes sir so you're teaching this in a
so what age group are you teaching
juniors and seniors or what um just
seniors and um we do economics from
january to may okay and woven into that
is foundations in personal finance that
is our entire economics course this year
wow
very cool thank you thank you yes sir
well we also heard that you had a
question what is it
um my question is i have students who do
have money in savings accounts but they
found out that that money is not really
growing it's growing at like point zero
five percent so they're getting a penny
every few months
where can i tell these 18 year olds
to
um a better place to put their money
where they see a little bit more return
on it
um versus a penny every few months
well the risk that goes with it might
not be worth it but you could go with
just an s p 500 index fund just to park
some money in a mutual fund for a period
of time the risk is is that it could
actually go down in value right
okay if the stock market goes down it
could go down
and so that's generally why i tell
people not to do that in these
situations
i would rather them use this money on
some form of education
okay the best investment these kids can
make is in themselves if they study
something use money to go to some kind
of school trade school college whatever
to study something that's actually
usable in the marketplace the actual
return on investment you spend ten
thousand dollars on education or you put
ten thousand dollars in a mutual fund
the actual math that you get back from
the ten thousand dollars will be greater
if it's on education that is usable that
has a utilitarian value in the
marketplace hey thank you karina for
teaching this we appreciate you that's
what we're here for this hour it's a
teacher appreciation financial literacy
month theme hour
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well in honor of financial literacy
month
and our high school curriculum taught in
about half the high schools in america
we are doing a teacher appreciation
giveaway this month
and we're appreciating teachers on the
air this hour as well now the teacher
appreciation giveaway works like this
we're giving away five thousand dollars
to two different teachers in cash and
you do not have to be a teacher that
teaches our stuff you just have to be a
teacher
no like a real teacher not like you
taught your dog to sit that's not what
i'm talking about you have to be like
teaching in a classroom and stuff and if
you're doing that then um we're gonna
we're gonna say yes you're like a real
teacher and we're gonna put sign let you
sign up for the drawing no purchase is
necessary just go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher ramsey solutions dot com slash
teacher and don't miss out this giveaway
ends on april the 30th so you've just
got a few more days to get signed up for
that and if you know a great teacher out
there that you've loved get in touch
with her get in touch with him and tell
them to make sure to run over to
rmcsolutions.com
teacher and register for this three give
a free giveaway they may be one of the
teachers that wins the
five
thousand dollars
cash
so uh up next is going to be wendy wendy
is a teacher in wisconsin and uh she's
been teaching our high school curriculum
as well hey wendy how are you
good thanks it's a pleasure to talk with
you gentlemen today you too and so where
do you teach which school
i teach at sheboygan salt high school in
wisconsin great very cool how many
students are enrolled there
oh i think it's probably about 1100.
okay very cool how long you've been
teaching
um 27 and a half years well you've seen
some changes
i definitely have
definitely some some of them good some
of them yeah what's the biggest change
you've seen working with young people
definitely some good some bad probably
the biggest challenge is
the
many different challenges that our
students come to us with very complex
home and family situations
but also
the digital challenges uh
our children today are growing up in a
digital world that we did not grow up in
that's right very true and we've got to
figure out how to navigate that how to
guide them how to parent in that world
it's it's a very different world than we
were raised in that's right
true that's very true yeah there's the
pre-television generation the post
television generation there's the
pre-smartphone generation the post
smartphone generation and it's it's uh a
lot of it is a blessing and a lot of it
is a curse
absolutely and there's a netflix and in
live streaming generation i mean they
don't turn on the tv like we did
no they don't they don't need to they
just when they want to see something
it's there right
it's on demand and so that's the way all
of us are now but most of us just didn't
realize it happened they they've it's
native to them they've never known
anything else so how long have you been
teaching our high school curriculum
foundations and personal finance
well i think it's been about 10 or more
years um a number of years ago you
hosted a teacher training institute and
i was fortunate to travel there with
another teacher and be trained on site
with your folks there at ramsey
solutions wow okay i remember doing that
yeah wow yes it was wonderful it's been
a while back we ought to do that again
that's good yeah you ought to do it
again
so did you have a question today as well
i do um as a teacher and honestly as a
parent myself also i'm caught in a bit
of a dilemma with the young people i
work with every day
i definitely want to inform them about
all the great digital tools the apps the
things they can use conveniently through
their smartphones to help them manage
their finances
but as i do this i find myself in a bit
of a dilemma struggling with
the gap that we're creating for these
kids
in terms of helping them understand the
tangible immediacy of cash
they're not using cash
they're not getting a paycheck and
cashing it they're not going to
pay for their gas with cash they're not
they don't have access to cash in the
same way we grew up
and so how can i balance that for them
when it's not in their hands like it was
for us
i i always want to roll back
pedagogically when i'm thinking about
how can i teach somebody i always want
to
how can i turn this into something they
can touch with their hands how they can
see right right and so i think
something that's important for kids
they've become untethered to the reality
of money right that it that i love the
way you put that i used to have to go
cash a check and i would hold the cash
and then i have to hand that to somebody
to get the thing they don't have that
exchange anymore and so they become
untethered from reality in the same way
they've become untethered with violence
and with sensuality because i can just
see it and see it and see and see it see
it so i would love to create a classroom
environment that is tethered in
reality
we are only going to operate with cash
in this class and you have to give that
cash to somebody else and so i'm going
to take every opportunity pedagogically
to re-ground them in human connection in
nope we're gonna practice how economics
works and you've got this money and that
person has a uh something you want and
we're gonna learn about supply and
demand but you have to get up and go
across that room and breathe that air
and hand them that cash right i'm gonna
get that basic because they're getting
the high level stuff digitally they're
just becoming increasingly untethered
from reality right
yep i think that's a great solution so
having sort of a token economy within
the classroom with maybe some dave cash
yeah or something
that's a great idea
the visual aspect of that changes it and
then i i think you teach the
uh i think you end up having a lesson on
the digital world
and facebook friends aren't real friends
yeah
virg virtual means sorta
yep snapchat exchange is not a
conversation it doesn't mean real it
means virtual it's not it's not real
virtual is not real
so when they say virtual reality it's an
oxymoron yeah it means almost absolutely
and so the uh you know and the same is
true so the beauty of the digital is
it's highly efficient
it's quick it's easily accessible it's
convenient
and the downside of it is you don't feel
it
whether it's relationships
or whether it's money
and i want them to feel it i want them
to feel that negative feeling that
prevents them from overspending that oh
i've got the this cash in my hand and i
really don't want to let go of it so if
they go to mcdonald's drive through and
try to pay with cash you know they're
asked do you want to use your app today
yep and here's another place i would
send them george campbell our friend
george campbell did a
i think it was a nine part series on his
podcast
that the fine price the fine print
podcast that is appropriate for their
age but it talks about
here's why um you know airline points
credit card points aren't that great
here's why
um this particular thing here's why uh
it sounds so good to get bitcoin here's
why that's not a good idea and it's
something that they're hearing about all
the time in a medium that they are
hearing about and so it will make you um
of course you're super way more hip than
me and dave but it will make you be hip
and you'll be able to pass along
something to them in a medium they can
understand and what i've seen with young
people is they get fired up when they
realize they're getting taken advantage
of or they get fired up when they
realize oh my points are coming on the
back of somebody who can't make their
payments and you you galvanize the the
justice here and then they're ready for
a conversation about here's how cash
works here's reality right and so i
would point you to the fine prints nine
episodes it's great but it's a tool that
it can be used and all all of these
ideas kind of fall in the same bucket
but one last one and it's uh we're doing
a lot of teaching on it it's going to
show up in a new lesson that john and
george did in financial peace university
here in the spring
um that uh
this idea of friction
um the the harder the more clicks you
have to do the harder the movement is
inside
of an app or inside of a website the
more sales go down
so the easier it is the more sales go up
and teach them that companies are
spending
tens of millions of dollars to
make it easier and easier and easier for
them because that company's gonna get
more and more and more of their money
and that's all that's all a mcdonald's
or a taco bell app or dunkin donuts app
is
you can order the donuts they'll be
sitting there on the counter you don't
stand in line it's easier it's easier
it's easier it's easier why because
their sales go up every time it's easier
it's so it's it's a it's a manipulation
is what it is
and it's it's perfectly fine but if you
know it's there but if you're 16 years
old and you just think it's cool then
you're gonna fall right into the bear
trap
so hey thank you for being one of the
best teachers in america grateful wendy
we appreciate you this is the ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today it is a teacher
appreciation hour during financial
literacy month this hour we're talking
with teachers and
crowing about teachers and bragging on
teachers we love teachers
and we love what they do
we think that they change the world
we know that they change the world so
we're taking questions from a few of
them
our high school curriculum financial
piece or i'm sorry
foundations in personal finance is
taught in about 45 percent of the high
schools now 48 of the high schools in
america has been taught in that many and
man it's absolutely um about 4 million
kids have now graduated from it it's uh
it's been a fun ride been a really
really really fun ride
so uh we thank you for that
our documentary borrowed future on
student loan debt the epic failure of
the student loan system the dark side
is the sponsor of our teacher
appreciation giveaway we're giving away
five thousand dollars to two lucky
teachers they will be drawn
randomly from the list of teachers that
register on our website for this free
giveaway no purchase is necessary if you
know a teacher or you are a teacher a
real teacher like in a classroom teacher
go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher and you can
get signed up for
the teacher appreciation giveaway you do
not want to miss it
so john i'm guessing that probably in
class
at 13 years old
you were an absolute terror dude i was a
joy i was calm
yeah i was a mess man i was a mess
as my wife tells me john you're a lot um
i think my a lot my 13 year old teachers
would tell me yeah i was a lot man that
was a lot
well i they just called it hyper yeah
when i went to school i mean that was a
thousand years ago yeah they just hyper
well
coach
that that hovered over me in a way that
it doesn't for young people today
the choir director or the math teacher
would say
if we can't sit still i'm gonna have to
let coach know so he can he can help
take care of this and
that straighten this up real real quick
um well i i you know the the strange
irony is i end up in talk radio we're
actually not talking is is not a good
thing dead here it gets real quiet right
here right now it's not a good thing in
radio you're supposed to keep the air
full uh i kind of have the same mindset
though in eighth grade there's not a
single teacher i've ever had who when
they found out i work in radio go yeah i
can see that not one i said really i'm
shocked you're you're such a you're such
a wall flower such a cool kid yeah
no that has never happened
every report card ever went home to the
ramsey parents said they've talked too
much oh okay they can't sit still so
yeah so we're we're those teachers worst
nightmares so we have to stop now as
adults and go thank you can i tell you
this though um the teachers
and again i know i sound like an old man
like i'm back in my day to go uphill
both ways
i feel like teachers when i was in
school
had the flexibility
both in the curriculum and in outcomes
and my parents were parents who
they trusted the teacher before they
trusted me all right a hundred percent
they were the opposite if they why
what's the opposite of a helicopter
yeah they're like i don't know
roto-rooter i don't know
a hedgehog i don't know my parents were
hedgehog parents i don't know they yeah
they just assumed that whatever happened
was my fault yes prove me otherwise
but but
i felt that they had the opportunity to
channel that energy and channel that
they could see that i wasn't a bad kid
they could see that i had good ideas but
hey let's let's push it this way and i'm
sitting here today because teachers
invested in me outside of the
traditional learning classroom the
outside like they would call me to their
office and have conversations with me
i'm here because teachers invested in me
man in my college professors too it's
it's i i it's neat to look back on a
group of people and say everything in my
life's because y'all um
y'all invested in me it's cool it's
awesome we were at a dinner party at our
house a little while back and around the
table were
very successful people in politics and
music and whatever
and we started talking about teachers
and every one of them i said everybody
tell me your favorite teacher no one
could
they all i mean 40 years ago
all had
teachers and name after name after name
after name and they couldn't choose
their favorite it's like trying to
choose your favorite movie your favorite
song too many options you know it's two
it's two it's too broad and so and they
all knew their names they could tell you
stories from the eighth grade they were
just as clear the pictures the the
painting was in hd
uh and that's the impact that these
teachers have and so we love you guys
out there and that's what we're doing
we're honoring you today tom is one of
the teachers of our high school
curriculum and he is in new hampshire
hey tom how are you i'm good how are you
guys so where do you teach i teach in
londonderry new hampshire all right and
uh and and what age group do you teach
it's a high school program nine through
12. okay and how many kids are in this
high school yeah about 1400 a little
over 1400 kids oh wow okay how long you
been teaching
i've been teaching
45 years i've been in this school 44.
wow
wow
you broken something the school opened
and i was like a second year teacher and
i've been here ever since you know where
all the bodies are buried in that school
don't you
and then some yeah
and some of the other schools too yeah
wow what a gift hey wow what a gift of
stability in the in the last several
years with so you've taught some of your
kids kids teacher mobility a lot of my
kids get i have plenty of kids who i've
had their parents um and um it's been a
blessing i've
to be
in this environment i have the
administration is great the teachers i
work with are amazing um
it's i've just been blessed to have this
opportunity to
end up where i ended up
you got a question today i do
um
um first of all i'm a shop teacher by
trade that's what i teach all these
years but i
went through ftu i've taught financial
peace or i've um
ran it you know did the program and
now i'm teaching it at the high school
level because i did the same thing you
were talking about earlier you know
these kids need to know this
and um
i'm teaching in a program that we have
here we called adult ed it's really an
alternative education program it's after
school for kids who can't make it in the
regular school day
um so a lot of these kids have been
tossed out or have trouble staying in
class or staying focused and that kind
of thing
the
issue that i have is that it's a
shortened
amount of time that i have with them
it's as as opposed to a regular school
day
i have them for an hour and a half for
two days a week for 14 weeks so i have
to take the program and trim it down
sure and kind of rifle through it and
pick the
you know the most important
topics to cover you know we cover
covered debt and
um budgeting and all the you know the
key things
um
and i don't have time to do any of the
activities so it's the the trick is
trying to keep them focused i had a
discussion with them today i just had
them this afternoon
and um so your question is what yeah the
question is how do i get these kids to
relate better um
you know do i
i've trimmed out as much as i can but
i'm almost afraid i most trim too much
sometimes
like
one of the things you always say is you
know you have to get to a point where
you say i've had it and i can't do it
anymore
that's what makes people change well
these kids haven't had enough experience
sometimes to get to that point and they
say oh this is nice stuff this makes
sense but i asked them today i said how
many of you have a budget and only one
kid in the class is working on a budget
and how many of you have an emergency
fund two of them are
having an emergency fund so here's
here's the
the the entry point into those kids
hearts and minds that are struggling
um
during the regular school day so much
they got to come in the afternoon the
key to their ability to learn
is trust in a stable adult
and one of the greatest gifts you can
give them as a classroom teacher
is to look at him and say i believe in
you and i trust you
it's not the content you know it is
creating a a world where they plug in
and say okay i trust this guy and he
makes me feel safe in fact he's the only
guy in my world that makes me feel safe
tell me more and then you teach them
maybe maybe you pull a concept out and
teach them how to budget right and
sometimes we get so concept heavy or
theoretical heavy teach that kid how to
budget make sure they don't leave your
class without a budget make sure they
see your budget up on the on the
blackboard they know how much you make
you're you're a teacher
let's let's make this personal let's get
them
that personal touch that personal impact
and then you're going to see some major
changes in those kids lives yeah what a
gift yeah they're gonna um
some of the teachers we were just
talking about before we picked up the
call
i don't necessarily remember the content
that they taught me what i remember is
that they cared
and they deeply impacted me because of
that
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you
[Music]
our scripture of the day as we head into
easter weekend
john 3 16 and 17 for god so loved the
world
that he gave
his one and only son
that whoever believes in him
shall not perish
but have eternal life
for god did not send his son into the
world to condemn the world
but to save the world
through
him
clarence hall said if easter says
anything to us today it says this you
can put the truth in a grave but it
won't stay there whoa i never heard that
one before it's pretty good
huh that one that that uh that's a good
one
wow powerful powerful stuff
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour we are featuring our
teacher appreciation giveaway sponsored
by the borrowed future documentary
exposing the dark side of the student
loan
industry
be sure and check it out and if you are
a teacher or you know a teacher please
send them to ramseysolutions.com teacher
to register for our teacher appreciation
giveaway in honor of financial literacy
month
and uh two teachers will win randomly no
purchase necessary a five thousand
dollar
cash gift each
and uh we invite you to send your
favorite teacher or teachers that are
maybe your second or third favorite
over to ramseysolutions.com teacher and
get them signed up our high school
curriculum has now been taught in 48
of america's high schools and over 4
million kids have been through it and
it's uh as a result of wonderful
fabulous teachers
like susan and susan everhart is a
teacher in ohio and she's on the line
hey susan thank you for what you do
thank you so much i appreciate it now
what what high school do you teach in
i teach at wadsworth high school in
wadsworth ohio okay and where's
wadsworth what's it near
um we're kind of in the medina
area oh yeah south of cleveland yeah
okay cool how many kids in this school
uh we have about 1400 9 through 12.
getting after it big operation how long
have you been a teacher
i have been teaching for 20 years this
is my 20th year wow and how long you've
been teaching found foundations in
personal finance uh yeah this is my
second year teaching the foundations
curriculum so still relatively new with
that but i'm loving it well cool well
thank you for being a high quality
teacher and thank you for teaching our
curriculum we appreciate you so you had
a question for today
i do um i with being in such a big high
school and the kind of different
socioeconomic levels of my students i
have anything from
you know kids that want for nothing to
kids that don't have much of anything to
want for
what advice can you give on how to make
kind of the content and the curriculum
really connect to every kid no matter
what their socioeconomic level may be
i'm going to go back to the same answer
i gave the last one
they're not going to understand abstract
numbers sometimes some of the kids may
understand a million dollars is what my
dad makes every year and other kids may
understand a million dollars is some
number they see on a game show right so
that's hard
for many high school kids even to
conceptualize
i want them to get to know each other
and i want to get them to get to know
the humanity of the people behind these
dollar amounts right or behind some of
the
um the big flashy things or the b or the
hand me down close i want them to know
each other and then be able to engage in
this material and i would challenge you
to not teach the principles differently
to those with less than those with more
the principles or the principles or the
principles and once they know each other
and they under have a context for each
other then everybody's learning the same
stuff together
that's great advice i love that
yeah and i
i think the thing i always want to give
to um
kids that
are not coming up in a
a household where everything is provided
they're you know it's a tough situation
is i want to show them evidence that
people like them
become millionaires give them a picture
yeah
and and show them evidence you know
stuff like the baby steps millionaire's
book and
because the information in that is a
whole host of people that become
millionaires uh did not start from any
kind of privilege
they literally started with no money but
even then they started a lot of times
with no privilege or or limited
privilege now everybody has a different
starting line
but uh but you know it doesn't matter
who what the starting line is all that
matters is what the finish line is
and so i want to give them hope and then
the the kids that are sitting in
uh uh
i don't like the word privilege in this
current environment but um
uh but because it's misunderstood and
miss but if the kids that are sitting in
a situation where everything's given to
them or where they don't have a worry in
the world
what i i do want them to have one worry
and that is if they don't go do it
themselves it's not going to happen
and so the disadvantage that they have
is that they may think it's going to be
automatic and it's not
it being success
okay and so i always want to disturb
those that are comfortable
and give hope to those that don't have
it
and that's awesome on both ends of the
socio-economic spectrum so you know
whether i'm speaking in a homeless
shelter or i'm speaking in a church
where the parking lot's full of mercedes
you know i'm going to craft my message
one of those ways and um because i i
want to disturb and make the comfortable
uncomfortable for their own good because
uh because that comfort will be your
destruction
and uh or keep you from being all you're
supposed to be in god's eyes and uh and
the hopeless you know if they don't go
move and move towards success because
they don't believe it can happen
then that's where we failed them we
didn't tell them it could happen and
that's the reason i did this last book i
really didn't have another book on my
agenda for the next uh five years but i
babysits millionaires i just got tired
of the hope steelers out there telling
people it couldn't be done i dave that's
that's a way better answer than the one
i gave i love that because you're
providing you're providing a picture of
a kid to a kid who like hey many of the
nfl football players who signed these
million dollar deals wind up broke
here's a picture of that and hey kids
here's what it takes to become a
millionaire and you can do it too even
though your parents haven't shown you
that picture your grandparents didn't
show that picture i'm going to give you
a picture of that that's beautiful yeah
you're the secret sauce in both of those
equations that's right you're the secret
sauce you're the secret sauce you're the
problem you're the solution you're the
problem you're the solution andrew is
also a teacher he's in pittsburgh andrew
thank you for teaching our stuff as well
man we appreciate you
thank you how are you great man how long
you been teaching foundations
um this is my 10th year
cool all right i'm up against the clock
so right quick thank you for that by the
way that's unbelievable uh what's your
question for john and i uh my question
is in just some background context i'm
always using supplemental information
whether it be the journal to use a story
about insurance i just used uh
your book uh the past couple weeks got
my hands on it
um
you guys use on a daily basis to
reinforce your beliefs
and everything that you teach
in terms of whether it be investing
or insurance or financial services
i'm a big believer in charlie munger's
philosophy which is before i develop a
position i need to know my opponent's
position better than they do
and so i spend a lot of my energy
reading things that might
go against what i think because i want
to know what the other folks are saying
about things
so
that that being said i wouldn't do that
to a bunch of middle school and high
school kids
i would probably push them to learn more
about why they make the decisions that
they make why they lump into why they
default to this or to that
how do they learn about how their
families work and what messages what
stories were they born into what stories
were they told because that's going to
frame a lot how they how they do money
what do you think dave
you know there's a lot to be said for
not being in an echo chamber and just
sitting and listening to people who
think you're just exactly like you all
the time or reading things that people
think just like about like you all the
time that that's kind of that's a
dangerous thing the other pro the
problem with getting outside of that and
searching out your opponent like john's
saying is you have to be careful to not
pollute your mind with trash that's
right
because there's a reason i disagree with
them and they're wrong
[Laughter]
that's america everybody
so you have to you have to temper that
with
with wisdom moderation
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you